c'est l'info qui faisait tous les titres
presse ce matin cyril hanouna qui s'en
prend violemment à l'ancien président de
la république françois hollande le
personne c'est qui sait vous êtes qui
monsieur merci et pour cause l'homme
politique n'a pas été très tendre avec
tpm paix lors d'une interview qu'il a
fait dans l'émission le qg touche pas à
mon poste qu'est cette motion droite
c'est ailleurs est ce que le quotidien
cette gauche quotidien c'est bien vous
l'avez compris françois hollande ne nous
a jamais vraiment porté dans son coeur
autant ce n'est pas faute de l'avoir
souvent invité s'il y en a donc profité
pour régler directement ses comptes il
n'y est pas allé de main morte quand
j'ai jamais pu blairer qu'il allait
croissant est en phase patxi le gars il
a été président pendant cinq ans on l'a
jamais vu on l'a vu ne soit pour une
sortie en scooter et mais croissant vous
y en a qui ont le kobe d'huile alter
minoritaire
alors le torchon brûle entre cyril
hanouna et françois hollande que s'est
il vraiment passé
[Musique]
comedia
on aurait pu
aller jouer au bowling au saint-françois
aurait pu faire plein de choses on
l'invité maintes et maintes fois dans
l'émission
nous a traités comme des moins que rien
bien emmanuel hubert ce soir merci ça
fait que le programmateur de l'émission
c'est toi qui en charge d'inviter des
invités tout à fait ça va c'est que
notre équipe de journalistes
programmateurs même les producteurs ont
leur éviter ne fait pas non plus une
mytho vous êtes deux
pas de raconter des histoires et autres
équipes ils sont deux donc un bellâtre 1
voilà donc où tomba donc plus à prendre
les gens pour des cons mais je suis très
content que tu te fout de toi tu es mon
ami voilà donc on doit en parler dans
l'instant et on à edouard dorian sippel
merci d'être là parce que c'était pas
évident parce que c'est vrai que le
torchon brûle entre françois et moi cet
ancien député ps et proche de françois
hollande est-ce qu'il va bien
aujourd'hui c'est la question que j'ai
envie de vous poser parce que il va très
bien il va très bien
pas trop triste cette amitié qui s'est
brisée si mais il va falloir re connais
un petit peu les morceaux on va
pierre-emmanuel qu'est ce qui s'est
passé avec françois l écoute je ne sais
pas c'est que depuis 2010 8 depuis le
début de lancement de balances ton post
on a essayé de l'inviter à maintes et
maintes reprises une dixième petit
moment sympa tient très sympathiquement
et sa concert presse et communication
nous répond à chaque plus adorable et
adorable elle nous répond à chaque fois
que c'est pas possible son emploi du
temps est compliqué que s'il n'est pas
dispo une prochaine fois elle nous a
jamais dit non il veut pas venir mais à
chaque fois c'est une prochaine fois
c'est que ça fait trois ans maintenant
qu'on attend qu'ils viennent dans
l'émission ou balances ton post goûter
pmp ou même septembre 6 à 7 ou aqua fou
c'est vrai que si tu que des missions
qui a tout à fait sa place dans l'axé en
politique alors françois long en plus
après il en a rajouté sur cette émission
je connaissais pas là le qg avec eux
guillaume pley avais je savais que je
produise et il est en plus produit
depuis la 6 et il en profite pour m'en
fous de ma gueule
corps et lui demain cet abruti non mais
c'est vrai il a tout raté lui rigole d
autres encore mais c'est vraiment lui
mais sans déconner darwin c'est bien son
nom de famille - festival d'angers même
pas que ça existait un ils ont tout fait
pour nous le vendre sur ses beats on
leur a refusé matin une louche il ya la
gueule c'est pas grave ça c'est toujours
pareil c'est le monde de la téloche on
en a rien à [ __ ] c'est magouille et
compagnie
autant que lui plus tard l'on dit oui si
ça restait un peu agaçant c'est que les
équipes de france hollande il ne
s'exprime pas pour le moment alors qu'il
est tout parent malade j'ai compté il a
fait 17 démission depuis la rentrée
c'est énorme depuis il a payé toutes les
chaînes à jouer en france 2 lci mais il
a même fait des émissions qu'on connaît
pas regarder on a même fait mais je les
fumées même qui est pas sur cette chatte
sur ce match a été vu sur un char
la tombe à voir sur animaux tbl n'est
pas mieux chez vous ceci dit moi je
l'avais je l'avais suivi pour un
documentaire j'avais parlé parce qu'on
voulait le faire rien d'emballant ce
compost et ça concerne avait dit qu'il
reconnaissait que vous aviez un humour
vous étiez très marrant quand même je
vous dire on va tout reprendre depuis
mardi on savait très bien passée c'était
très bien partie due aux essais mais
bien alors quoi alors alors regarde
regarde un peu patrick bruel
on s'était vus à l'elysée un jour parce
que je te jeu de passer par là
il veut dire en deux minutes
et quand même une imagerie babani prend
un petit truc tu veux un 4/4 un truc
sympa quoi le garnement donc on mange du
guillemot dont se régalent les ondes
arca tu vois et françois oued
francescoli l'appel pièce compte unique
et un petit côté libanais et là on s'est
plus jamais revu et là il a commencé à
m'attaquer de partout de partant de
partout et là eduardo rien de si belles
merci des termes est ce si bel on
n'avait rien à voir là dedans je veux
vraiment pas un grand chantier attaquer
que se passe-t-il avec françois
sylla quelconque grief contre moi qui me
disent j'ai détesté ce qu'il a dit dans
cette émission
c'était méchant on est d'accord bernard
montiel excusez-moi de vous réveiller à
19 heures
non ce n'était pas la tasse on lui issus
tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
mais lui tant qu'il sait pas qui va avec
le président il dit leila six mois là ça
va être sus à la poubelle
et la plaque nda ça pendant sibeko
merci ecology bas mais je suis pas de
vous méfiez-vous va cardiaque soit
président qu'il foute dehors alors
eduardo qu'est ce qui s'est passé
je crois qu'il a un agenda il fait la
tournée de son bouquin mais moi je crois
qu'il a autant d'humour que vous alors
il paraît super bien c'est vraiment un
tel parce que on a l'impression que
c'est un boycott bassin boycott moi j'ai
vu tous les échos monde a invité
dernièrement pour son livre au mois
d'octobre qui choisit ses stocks et
c'est vrai qu'il nous a dit non pas
possible à gendarmes disponibles on l'a
vu sur c'est à vous comme on l'a vu on
est en direct quotidien c'est que fait
tous les talk shows sauf le nôtre sur le
chercheur car peut-être car ce sont pas
peut-être ce ne sont pas et je le ferai
jamais bon j'ai rien sourire et lui
parler de ce petit chagrin d'amour alors
et on essaiera de faire une petite
médiation et eduardo juste eu le truc
c'est que aujourd'hui moi qui ne veulent
pas faire l'émission je comprends tout à
fait moi aussi à plein des missions que
je veux pas faire même si j'adore les
gens par exemple j'étais invité plein de
fois sur animaux tv par un ami
aujourd'hui sur rfm également j'ai
vraiment décliné toutes les invitations
puisque c'est une radio voilà voilà qui
était tenu par des gens que je te
raconte pas
oui qui nous critiquent ça ça m'a fait
mal parce que je l'aimais beaucoup
françois gemenne des projets pour lui
d'inviter oui demain l'invité au
déjeuner d'anniversaire de mon fils
est là il a tout foutu en l'air donc
voilà donc est-ce que vous pensez que ça
peut se rabibocher avec françois eduardo
mais bien sûr mais je pense que françois
est un c'est un mec intelligent d'une
part il paraît une grande intelligent il
était président quand on
regarde ce vraiment moque souvent
françois hollande il a été président de
la mx arrive pas par hasard à ces atouts
d'une part et d'autre part c'est
quelqu'un qui
s'il a une qualité c'est non seulement
l'humour il a un humour
gigantesque et très léger et très très
encline à rien contre d'un arrière non
je crois pas du tout je pense que j'ai
compris ce qu'il a dit à propos de votre
émission il faut le prendre comme une
petite provocation au pire bienveillante
amical c'est c voilà une façon de vous
charriez de jouer à votre propre dieu
merci je crois que vous manquez beaucoup
manifestement
eduardo vous êtes en train de recoller
les morceaux mais bon voilà ces mots
c'est mon sens soissons tu me regardes
françois moi aussi j'ai pleuré cette
nuit
moi si je me suis dit j'ai fait était
trop loin avec françois parce que je
suis j'ai revu des photos de toi tu
gardé plein de photos et j'ai mis
la même
reprise de dany brillant grand fond et
je me suis dit
que j'étais à la maison et de regarder
les photos de toi françois je me suis
dit lui et moi il faut qu on recolle les
morceaux
comme un puzzle
mais toutes les pièces ne sont plus
manquant entre maintenant françois on
n'a plus qu'à se retrouver seule chose
que je te demande ne vient pas avec anne
hidalgo
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]